alif thing d'envergure pour les
logements du quartier bernard de jussieu
à versailles les contours du futur
projet ont été dévoilés ce mercredi 14
novembre
l'isolation et les façades vont être
totalement refaite les artistes
internationaux vont également dessiné 9
fresque géante sur les pignons les
fresques elle même ne sont pas connus on
ne connaît que les artistes 1 qui sont
qui ont été choisis qui ont été choisis
pour avoir des fresques quand même assez
élégant quelque chose d'assez apaisants
dans son décor et donc les artistes
maintenant bon choix a travaillé sur le
choix des fresques avec le thème de la
nature qu'il aurait été imposée on veut
quelque chose d'apaisant des presque
élégante et apaisante avec ses fresques
la ville espère pouvoir attirer dans le
quartier les habitants du centre ville
mais également des touristes français ou
étrangers sur le modèle de lyon
précurseur en la matière le quartier
bernard de jussieu et accolé à la forêt
est donc un peu en cul de sac
au jour d'aujourd'hui ne vienne à
bernard de jussieu que des gens qui y
habitent ou viennent voir quelqu'un qui
connaisse à bernard de jussieu donc
l'intérêt des fraises qui est de faire
venir de l'extérieur dans ce quartier
donc de donner une fierté aux habitants
parce que c'est leur quartier sera
reconnu par des gens de l'extérieur il
nouvelle accueillie avec enthousiasme
par les 6000 habitants du secteur
au départ ils ont été un peu surpris
mais ils se rendent compte
que très vite et très vite en discutant
avec les artistes que ça va apporter un
plus la livraison définitive du projet
est programmée pour le premier trimestre
2001 21 coût total de l'opération plus
de 26 millions d'euros